what's it really like being a Muslim in
Britain today with the rise in hate
crimes and a growing prejudice towards
Islam how do Muslims really feel the
far-right believe there's an Islamic
conspiracy to take over from within and
why are some young Muslims leaving
Britain for the killing fields of
Syrians in the first survey of its kind
we've asked Muslims and non-muslims
about the big issues of Britain today do
I need to stand up with the placard and
say I am an integrating slip we've asked
them about life in their community are
we talking about integration or a
simulation about radicalization and
jihad new experience doors being bashed
down you experience being arrested I
think you get the same response from
people about their doors kick down from
the the non-muslim community as well and
the results have been surprising we've
brought Muslims and non-muslims from
across the country together to talk
about our findings we asked a thousand
Muslims and the same number of
non-muslims to answer questions on a
cross-section of issues the results are
fascinating and show whilst the two
groups agree on some things there are
significant divisions that still exist
when asked about British values and
whether they considered Islam to be
compatible with it our survey revealed
some stark differences in views more
than 70% of British Muslims said that
generally Islam was compatible with
British values but more than half of
non-muslims disagreed thinking Islam
wasn't instead Simon and Miranda are
neighbors and friends for about half an
hour
they agree on some things but not on
others remember them and I'm not what
else I drink you don't I think you don't
yeah I think I think the differences are
clearly there because
in terms of our social lives the best
like this small that's like not
important no three and I think the
friendships it may be very nailed it I
do difference I think that that
supersedes although we might have very
different social lives and maybe I some
ideas and whatever but really the
friendship supersedes that so do they
have different views when it comes to
Family Values
specifically marriage I would be looking
at suitable matches for my children I
would be looking at somebody with good
Muslim values I would be looking at
somebody with maybe somebody that could
maintain my my children my mother
wouldn't have picked my husband for me
and I would and likewise my mother she
didn't pick my husband but what my
mother said is you can marry whoever you
want but there are certain criteria that
we would be happy that you fulfilled in
Preston students Alicia Ali and Tom
konstantinovich looked at the same issue
our poll found that among younger Muslim
women 1/5 felt Islam was out of step
with British values but those Alicia
agreed I don't drink
just because it's not because it's like
he's a lot of it is religion but I feel
like I can have a good time without
drinking and it's not being something
I've been brought up with I don't really
need it because I've done fine without
it so far what do you think about
British courts you have to go out get
obviously you have it I think everyone
has their own way of like letting
letting go and like loose and if that's
the way that some people want to do it
that's like fine by me I mean each their
own
the rise in a number of young Muslim men
and women leaving Britain to join
fighters in Syria is a big issue at the
moment nearly 40% of the Muslims we
asked said they partly blamed the police
and security services
actually radicalizing young Muslims just
16% of non-muslims agreed but half of
those non-muslims we asked said they
didn't agree that police in mi5
contributed to the radicalization of
young Muslim men Brainware tone is a
former Metropolitan police officer
muhammad khaleel advises the police on
how to engage Muslim communities I think
the difference between two figures 40%
for the Muslim community and 16% for the
non-muslim community is because of the
perception possibly within the Muslim
community and maybe in my view I think
that's slightly wrong I think there's
been some messages going out that the
the police and security services are
very heavy-handed and not to be trusted
a dishonest that there's there's
incidents have been widespread ly
reported all over the place I'll tell
you why there's a difference in
perception between the Muslim community
and the non-muslim community with the
way they perceive the experiences of the
police and security services falls down
to one thing
do you experience what Muslims
experience you experience doors being
bashed down you experience being
arrested locked up and in many cases
released but nobody's there to exonerate
you afterwards and that pain remains
with you for a long time and that word
gets out into the community policing
needs to change and be proportionate and
fair I agree it needs to change to be
proportionate fair I think it is
proportionately I think you get the same
response from people about their doors
kick down from the the non-muslim
community as well I think it's the same
well how can it be proportionately
unfair if you look at the stats the
number of Muslims that are arrested and
then just released through the backdoor
but the papers have still put their
pictures all over the front pages they
still seems stigmatized for life a lot a
lot of people sort of think that maybe
the mi5 and the police are partly
responsible for the radicalization of
young young was the man like you think
that's fair
personally I think maybe
blaming the police on mi5 isn't the
right way to go about things I think
like maybe if you're you feel like
you're being harassed by by these
organizations then maybe you might get
their sort of them vsauce mentality it's
this dishonest spying on communities
trying to bring out the worst which
doesn't exist that's causing the
problems there is a strategy for trying
to stop young Muslims from being
attracted into terrorism
it's called prevent and it's not without
its critics we asked who should do the
preventing 44% of Muslims and 65% of
non-muslims said family had the biggest
role to play
Angemon was spends her time trying to
get Muslim communities to integrate more
Jahangir Mohammed is an expert on
terrorism issues what makes a 14 15
year-old girl pecker bugs and said you
know I'm going to become a jihad a bride
is that a normal thing to do she been
radicalized through the internet it's
something Jacqueline I couldn't somebody
use looked into that can understand
what's happening I can understand what
zoning I don't you know the I don't
endorse what they're doing but you have
to understand that young people these
days are interacting in their bedrooms
purely through the internet and that the
message of the propaganda coupled with
the fact that they feel that their their
lives are being intruded they can't live
their lives as Muslims in Britain young
people are being persuaded there's a
strong propaganda come to come to Syria
there's a house there's a car there's
jobs that we're creating a state you're
saying to me that you understand is
almost condoning their no no it's not
condoning that it's saying I understand
the the draws that are taking place a
lot of people are going out to Syria for
humanitarian reasons they are very angry
with what's happened they
these pictures of babies suffering
houses destroyed mas destroyed it might
be best intentions to go out there and
prevent whatever happen but racing the
fan so fans aren't going in the right
places that the efforts out there are
not going in the right places against it
or terrorism
and I think the message needs to come
out from the Muslim community you're not
supporting the right the right the right
means here you're not doing the right
things here you actually need to stop
what's going on out there but maybe for
internet here preventing people going
out I think a lot of people see that and
as your lads going over to Syria and I
mean I'm just worried what do you think
of that do you think that's a doing it's
a lot of young Muslim logic that's
damaging for your perception of Islam
I think people are really frightened of
terrorism ugly and yeah and it's more
fear thing than a racist thing towards
Muslims I think I don't know I think
there's a lot of people it were they
were quite narrow-minded you you will
associate or Muslims with what is going
on yeah we're using the name of Islam in
a way that is totally alien to the 99%
of Muslims are you with that
on the issue of integration and whether
some Muslim communities do enough to
play a part with non-muslim neighbors
our survey revealed yet more splits in
opinion two-thirds of Muslims we asked
said they do enough to integrate into
society but 58% of non-muslims said they
believed their Muslim neighbors didn't
do enough to get involved is it almost
an insistence that you know or a
narrative that Muslims are not
integrating so people are looking out
for those non integrating people what is
integrating I mean you and I are friends
when we talk what is integrating you
know we go to school how did we meet
through school you know do I need to
stand up with a placard and say I am an
integrating slim surely not and then I
have to say and I mean we've got kids
we both worn out we both have kicked
bags in football boots and packed
lunches and and dinner money and
homework and that's what life is about
and friendship I just wonder if there's
a problem with language here are we
talking about integration or a
simulation that that for me that is a
problem because I see integration
happening it's like the British when
they go to Spain they stick together
they stick together millions of pounds
have already been spent trying to pull
communities together they call it
community cohesion our survey has
revealed some stark divisions in society
but it's also revealed some common
ground to me British values are queuing
British values are looking after your
neighbor a British values are that we
care for each other British values are
very much that we accept people who come
from a different culture and I think
that is bad that's exactly what means
the Muslims are not very good at queuing
you know I think it's interesting
because obviously you're your own person
yes I happen to be a practicing Muslim
but that has really never reviewed his
papal it's not a pizza autistics it's
not this it's not that it's just
thanks just being friends yes which we
are yes sorry you again